what up space fam golson here from anime
up pro and i'm back at it again to
discuss
the latest episode of the attack on
titan final season
this episode explored aaron's
transformation and end goal
the next attack time user and mikasa's
secret identity among other crazy things
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
time videos i want to keep them coming
then the best that you could do
is warhammer smash that like button
really destroy it
show it no mercy if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
time videos that's just the way it works
and while you wait for the next insane
episodes to drop feel free to check out
our growing attack on time playlist
where we got videos about anything you
can imagine from all titan shifters and
their powers explained to all
ackermann's explained to the titans
ranked from weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into it so this episode
begins with aaron in the mirror
telling himself to fight while hanji
overhears him
he's in the prison after designing by
himself to attack marley despite what
everyone else
thought hanji asks what does this mean
why is he talking to himself and what's
he fighting
obviously we can't know for sure but we
can assume things one theory is that
aaron is not completely in control of
himself right now
as we saw with reiner you can have a
split personality within one person but
with aaron he's inherited three titan
powers at this point and likely many of
the memories of their past users
no one's ever had so many titan powers
in them since the series started
so there's no telling how much of a
psychological impact this can have on
someone
i've also always had a theory that the
attack titan specifically has its own
will
because we are told it always moves
forward seeking freedom no matter what
whatever the case as hanji points out
aaron is looking a bit crazy here
talking to himself
and probably just trying to pump himself
up to do what's important and stay on
track despite the fact that sasha died
and that many more will probably die
before he's completed his mission who's
aaron fighting
possibly himself more likely the
marlenes and everyone
else who's trying to eradicate the
aliens on the island who are his closest
friends in all the world
mainly as was the case in attack of time
before fighting is associated with
fighting for survival like when he told
mikasa you need to fight to win
and if you don't win you die this led
her to killing the kidnapper who was
about to kill aaron fighting meant
killing the kidnappers but it also meant
saving their own lives
my guess is this fight fight mantra he's
telling himself
is also reminding him that he needs to
fight for his survival
and for the survival of his people like
mikasa and armin hanji has some funny
moments here saying that aaron's hair is
cool
and calling him a pervert after he
points out that they have no power he
can use the warhammer titan power to get
out of prison any time
and they can't kill him because they
need the falling titan power the whole
imprisonment is a charade
and hanji can only joke about everything
calling aaron a pervert in his
rebellious phase
rather than admitting that he's right
aaron has all the leverage here it seems
like
and hanji deeply questions irwin's
decision to leave her
in charge hanji also mentioned that she
never thought aaron would sacrifice
historia by which she means that by
agreeing to go along with zeke's plan
it means that historia will have to
inherit the beast titan power
since she's the only one with royal
blood and she'll have to have as many
kids as possible before she dies
so there are more royal blooded users in
the future as we later figure out
historia didn't get into a relationship
because of love but out of necessity she
picked a man to have children with
we'll touch upon this again later but
it's a big deal because aaron has always
tried to protect historia remember he
never admitted the truth about his
founding titan awakening when he touched
a royal blooded titan because he was
scared about what the military would do
to historia later in this episode in a
flashback he even said screw
zeke's plan if it meant historia
breeding like cattle but i think
it will all make sense in the end i
don't think he forgot about historia and
those closest to him at all even if he
is keeping them at arm's length right
now
we find out that levi kept yelling and
aaron from really working together
clearly the military is careful about
aaron getting too close to zeke and his
people
and that's obvious after they took zeke
to the titan forest
but one of the biggest reveals was that
mika says actually
hizuru royalty hizuru is pretty much the
japan of the attack on tight world and
their current representative is kiyomi
both mikasa and kiyomi are part of the
azumabito
family the ruling family of the nation
we see mikasa reveal the tattooed symbol
of the family the three swords that look
like the apple app store logo that she
had on her arm the whole time
it's a bit weird that she kept it hidden
this whole time especially since she'd
have to
remove the bandage every time she
showered and put it back on and field
questions if anyone saw it
but her mother told her to keep it a
secret and we must assume that she was
very disciplined in doing that aaron did
know about it another sign of how
special he is to mikasa that she would
keep no secret from him no matter how
important
even though he's been keeping her
completely in the dark about his plans
and motives recently
although it would be nice to believe
that the hizuru nation wants to help the
ldns because it's the right thing to do
and because mikasa is one of their own
but the truth is they want
the resources on the island namely the
ice burst stone
which is very important in the age of
modernization it will mean money and
military might for them and of course
they want to restore hizuru to its
former glory first and foremost
not just altruistically help the aldians
just because they had a connection in
the past
you have a moment where kiyomi is very
much revealed to be a money grubber
as she practically salivates from the
mouth at the mention
of the ice burst stones and what it
could do for her and her nation
we hear about the three things needed
for zeke's plan which remember is
supposed to lead to the freedom of the
aldean people according to the last
episode they need a
a test run of the rumbling aka they need
to flex on the world with the colossal
titans in the walls
so as to let them know what could happen
if they mess with the island
b they need his little cooperation and c
they need to continuously pass down the
founding titan and the beast titan to
someone with royal blood
so that they will continue to have
access to the rumbling which should act
as a deterrent against enemy attacks
this last part is what a lot of people
including erin have a problem with
because of what it means for historia
but historia agrees to do it if it means
their survival
as a queen she wants her people's
survival even if it means she has to
become a titan and have babies with a
man she doesn't love
but keep in mind aaron hated this idea
of historia having to become a titan and
forcing her children to eat her
before the process repeats itself again
and again until they reach some vague
point in history
where the world might be on peaceful
terms with aldians and the aldians have
developed strong enough technology
so they don't need titans to deter enemy
attack at this point in the flashback
eren wants to explore
other options options that don't involve
historia sacrificing herself so in this
episode we get to see how aaron went
from wanting to explore other options to
deciding to attack marley
unite with zeke and seemingly agreeing
with his plan
that he so hated in the first place but
yeah let's keep hanji's question in mind
moving forward does
aaron care about historia still or not
we do
see that historia is pregnant in the
present day and she doesn't look happy
the father appears to be a farm boy who
was mean and then nice to her in the
past and she hand-picked him we see
officials talking about the queen over
wine in a very
very disrespectful way calling her a low
bred queen
and wanting her to become a titan
immediately and inherit zeke's beast
titan
even if it costs her the child there is
also speculation that yelena told her to
have a baby asap
because if the queen is pregnant zeke
lives a bit longer this
explains why they didn't immediately let
historia eat zeke
because if she loses the baby and
anything happens to her
their ability to use the rumbling and
their future is gone the question
is is aaron going to be able to find a
way to prevent historia and her children
from having to go through the torture of
becoming titans that remains to be seen
until historia actually eats zeke there
is a niccolo
in the basement moment where there's a
focus being placed on the wine he's
giving
this scene seems random af so for anime
only watchers feel free to let me know
your theories on the significance of
this scene in the comments
we then again jump to a flashback where
our crew
including a less jaded aaron is working
on a railway
there are some highlights here like how
people are grasping for straws
on how to avoid the rumbling and how to
save historia even though it doesn't
seem likely and how levi is a bit peeved
that even connie
has gotten so much taller than him that
was a pretty hilarious touch in the
middle of the usual darkness
then here's the kicker they can't turn
to hizuru he's wants to monopolize the
island's resources themselves
so they're not going to help them create
peaceful ties and trading relationships
with other places greed has messed up
their plans
it's also mentioned that the world
thinks the island is the root of all
evil and that that belief helps to unite
all nations and bring stability to the
world i think that's an important idea
to keep in mind like lelouch took on the
world in code geass and made everyone
think that he was the bad guy so they'd
unite in their hate for him
it's possible by attacking marley aaron
wanted to begin a narrative that he's
the root of all evil not the island and
so he can take pressure off of his
friends
we'll see but this line suggests that
nations constantly need
some root of evil to band together
against so we'll see who that may turn
out to be
at the end of attack on titan levi says
there is no choice with the
circumstances presented
but to rely on the rumbling and to
sacrifice historia there's the idea that
maybe the world fears them because they
don't know
them and they need to meet them and
maybe things will change if the world
knows they want
peace but as we saw in the last episode
there is a lot of time
needed for this plan to possibly work
the majority of our lanes that made it
to the island
got locked up because they refused to
work with the aldians
so aaron eventually decided he needed to
buy time on his own but
not yet and not here in this flashback
he is more hopeful and innocent
there are conversations of who might
inherit aaron's attack
titan mikasa offers but they need her
for hizuru relations
and they don't know if ackerman's could
even become titans and what that would
look like
jean offers but they need his leadership
for more than 13 years
connie offers but he's too dumb
according to sasha sasha offers and
connie points out that she's even dumber
than he is
i laughed out loud during these moments
but finally aaron shares his true
feelings which i think are driving all
his actions right up to the present day
aaron doesn't want any of them to
inherit the power because they are
important to him
more important than anyone else he wants
them to have long lives
it's a moment of vulnerability and he
turns red and then everyone else turns
right into phase two
and they just blame it on the sunset
it's a nice vulnerable beautiful moment
and they mentioned later that aaron is a
completely different person in the
present
than he was back then but i don't buy
that i believe
we still know aaron's end goal which as
he said was to prioritize these people
who are closer to him than anyone else
and to ensure that they live
long lives as best as possible i believe
he wants to find a way to save historia
and all of these guys from having to
become titans or dying and that's
exactly what he's trying to do right now
if that means he had to sacrifice
marlene lives then he's willing to do it
people are questioning aaron the present
day except mikasa and i really love
her undying trust and support in aaron
but that may just be me
everyone else doubts him while mikasa
still wears the scarf he gave her they
mentioned that only aaron and zeke
know what they spoke about and that
aaron seems to be on board with zeke's
plan now
aaron in their view is siding with his
half-brother over them
i really don't know why they think aaron
is acting against them if he's working
with zeke
as far as they know zeke's plan can
actually be what's best for them
maybe there isn't trust in zeke after
what he did to
so many of the survey corps members but
there should definitely be more trust in
aaron in my view
connie straight up mentions that they
gotta be prepared to kill aaron
again wtf is that logic for me
it's jumping the gun hardcore as mikasa
says aaron cares about them more than
anyone
and that is why he's more hostile to
anyone like the marlenes who isn't them
in mikasa's view they should trust him
more he's acting like
this because he cares too much two
narratives are developing here
one from almost everyone besides mikasa
that says
aaron has changed he used to want them
off the front lines and this time he
dragged them into a dangerous battle
while mikasa suggests
that he did so because he trusted them
there's no mention that if aaron didn't
do what he did
then there's a possibility that they
would all have died and not just sasha
but that's not how most see it
they mentioned how sasha died because of
aaron and how erin laughed wondering
what was funny about her death
and i'm completely going to defend aaron
here a sasha's last words were hilarious
b people react differently in the face
of tragedy and just because people laugh
doesn't mean that they aren't hurting
and see we saw aaron's face after
sasha's death and it was one of the most
powerful images in all attack on titan
so far
aaron's face was completely contorted in
pain he was clearly suffering
assuming he just thought it was funny
and that he wasn't hurt is just
ignorant aaron was crushed because he
still believes in my view that he's
doing what he's doing for these friends
and one of them died because of his
actions but he can still save the rest
and that is what he's going for
he knows there will be sacrifices but
he's going to try to save as many as
possible
from tragic destinies armin decides that
mikasa and him will talk to aaron on
their own
and try to find out his goal like i said
i think it's to save them
but only time will tell even armin
though is talking about
ending aaron mentioning that if aaron
has the same plan as zeke
they got titan serum and could let
someone they trust eat aaron
and take the founding titan from him
again why are people so sure
zeke's plan sucks maybe i'm missing
something and if i am please let me know
in the comments
here i'm definitely leaning the most
towards mikasa in my thought process
we also see zeke and levi chilling men
are drinking that juicy wine around them
zeke is reading which i can respect
because i absolutely
love my books not gonna lie this is a
pretty nice scene
although with zeke and levi in the same
place you can never know how long the
peacefulness will last
lastly we figure out in the preview that
gabby and falco
escape from prison and what's this they
meet devils who are nice to them
shocker we can look forward to seeing if
gabi changes her mind about these island
devils when she figures out that they
are
literally exactly like all the people
back on the continent
and maybe the one she meets is even
nicer than most of those
the title is called deceiver and that is
it for this episode review
it was an amazing episode with so much
information we learned
a lot definitely about aaron's end goal
about aaron's transformation
and about just in general how everyone
is feeling right now
because has always been best girl for me
and i think she's
in the right here as well but as i keep
saying only time will tell let me know
your thoughts about the episode and
where you think we're going from here
let's start a conversation in the
comments if you do enjoy seeing these
attack on titan episode reviews and want
to keep them coming then the best thing
you can do is warhammer smash that like
button
destroy it if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos that's just the way it
works
and while you wait for the next insane
episode to drop feel free to check out
my growing attack on time playlist where
we got videos about all the titan
shifters and their powers
all the ackermans and their powers the
times rank for weakest the strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord
tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans ingrata the
world acquire respect pate heffa
liam thompson al-jatal dr cortman
johnny boy draws emperor otaku spidey
life tinel baked buddhist and tungsten
tarkis
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsuki joe stanton very gucci
jessica kayla fond rathu and aura alicia
actor bonnie parks hinokami and water
the red haired raven joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as low as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully already
destroyed
so yeah you can support work on that way
if you prefer and whichever way you
choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you